Roger stone is flamboyant a provocateur
and the man who shaped Donald Trump's
political image and encouraged him to
run for president
he's also been a close personal friend
of the president for decades so when
federal prosecutors from the Justice
Department recommended stone served
seven to nine years in prison Trump took
the unusual step of intervening in the
case I think it's a disgrace stone was
caught up in Special Counsel Robert
Muller's investigation into Russian
interference in the 2016 election a
grand jury indicted stone on seven
counts including witness tampering and
lying to investigators prosecutors also
accused him of threatening witnesses
stone was found guilty last year and is
awaiting sentencing on Tuesday Trump
tweeted the sentencing recommendation of
seven to nine years was a miscarriage of
justice later in the day the Justice
Department revised its recommendation
for sentencing prompting criticism that
the president was abusing his powers no
I have not been involved with it at all
by Tuesday evening all four federal
prosecutors here at the Justice
Department that were working the case
have reportedly stepped down in protest
and the top Democrat in the Senate is
accusing the president of acting
inappropriately Roger stone should get
the full amount of time the prosecutors
recommended it all comes less than a
week after the president was acquitted
by the Senate on charges of obstruction
of Congress and abuse of power
some critics now feel the president
feels emboldened by the acquittal so
he's basically saying he will wield the
instruments of power to favor his
political friends and punish his
political enemies Trump voters likely
won't see this as the president doing
anything wrong
however Democrats in Congress might see
otherwise and argue it's another example
of the president getting involved in
something he shouldn't Gabriel as andö
al Jazeera Washington